hey guys it's vadim with maxtec and this
right here is apple's mac pro and inside
of it is the absolute best graphics card
that you can get on any mac ever for
gaming it's the
w6900 from amd and it costs a massive 6
000
and we've been testing it for the last
couple of days and i'm pretty sure we're
the first ones on youtube or the
internet to put out the benchmarks as we
did in the other video so if you're
interested in looking at those
definitely watch that video but for this
one we are gonna be doing something very
interesting we're gonna be doing some
gaming and i'm extremely excited because
you literally cannot get better gaming
performance with any other card
combination including the new
w6800x duo because while you're gaming
it only uses one of those chips so the
6900x is the best so i'm gonna put this
guy down and as you guys can see right
here we have windows installed using
bootcamp before we begin i do want to
download geekbench5 you can see the
radeon pro
w6900x right there let's go ahead and
run it and while this is running i do
want to mention that this mac pro has
the 12 core xeon cpu with a 192
gigabytes of ram that we installed
ourselves and saved a ton of money so if
you want to see how to do that
definitely watch our tutorial video
alright so here we go that is extremely
disappointing 98 000 points in vulcan
that just does not seem right
i'm actually going to go ahead and run
the opencl test because that's that's
very low and here we have the opencl
score that is a lot better
140 000 but that is still not quite what
we saw on mac os running geekbench we
actually got
170 000 points which is awesome it's
actually really really good the best
graphics performance you can get in any
single gpu graphics card on a mac now
with that said before we get into
playing some call of duty and some grand
theft auto 5 let's go ahead and switch
over to the mac and play some metro
exodus let's go over to the options 6k
resolution with the pro display xdr that
is absolutely insane i'm going to start
off with the quality on high motion blur
on low because that does not matter uh
the texture filtering on the lowest
level which is af 4x so let's go ahead
and try that out would you look at that
6k is insane like all right i'm looking
like super close on these details and i
cannot believe the amount of detail i'm
able to see like tiny little specks of
snow looking like right up front that is
just
insanity oh man this is weird all right
let's go
oh
spiders dude i can't see up
dude he was serious dude
this game's creepy bro
what in the world all right bro
boom
boom oh no he's not dead
oh let me re-road oh
all right so far it seems like at high i
don't think i'm getting 60 fps i mean
you guys can see because this has shot
it
at 60 but doesn't seem perfectly smooth
almost like i'm getting around 40 50
sometimes it might dip down
so i mean 6k at high yo 6k at high
doesn't really pull 60fps so far
i'm gonna go into the options and i'm
gonna turn it down to 6k medium oh dude
how am i supposed to kill these dudes
oh
let me in bro
bro
[Music]
all right this this right here is 60 for
sure
all right 6k medium that is very solid
60fps i can't believe you could
literally play with the 6900x
at 6k resolution 60fps that's it's
incredible all right with that said
let's get out of here let's try out
those other games and actually get an
fps counter going all right now we're
back in windows and as you can see grand
theft auto 5 6k baby oh actually look
i'm gonna run the benchmark tests first
which is gonna be very interesting to
see how it runs compared to other
systems other graphics cards look at
that we're starting off with what like
140 130 fps all right now checking up on
the benchmark results we've got around
124 through 142
average fps that is pretty impressive
i've got to say and right now we're
sitting at around 120
fps i actually want to try out directx
11. look at that we're getting a 140 fps
now so 11 is definitely giving us some
better fps this is insanely smooth yeah
it's perfect
my bad man let's go down to 4k alright
guys hundred and eighty-eight
all right we getting out of here now
gotta lose the cops oh no there's more
cops man oh snap oh he's ramming me now
all right let's play some gta online
before we switch over to call of duty
all right so now we're playing gta
online and the fps is definitely lower
69
68 fps for some reason let me just try
out 6k
let's just see all right 6k is now on
and we are getting basically the same
fps 65 it didn't really go down that
much 74 right there 4k at 60 hertz still
around 100 fps and now finally let's go
back up to 6k almost 100 fps wow guys
100 fps
6k gta online all right and with that
said let's go ahead and exit this game
and play one of my favorite games out
there call of duty warzone here we are
in the graphics settings you can see
we've got the pro display xdr we've got
60 screen refresh rate and let's bring
the display resolution to a hundred
percent we're gonna have no frame rate
limit looks like we got texture
resolution set to high and you can see
all that right now and i am going to try
ray tracing a little bit later just to
see how it looks but there you go 78 81
fps guys at 6k super smooth gameplay wow
this is impressive not even a stutter
man
you did alright just to make this
interesting i'm gonna bring it down to
4k look at that 140 134 nice 4k at high
settings textures normal let's do that
oh you serious
what
yes
all right just because i'm curious let's
go down to 1080p i just want to see how
much fps we can get all right guys this
is weird 1080p didn't make a difference
either 4k ray tracing 100 fps guys and
everything looks
beautiful i'm doing it 6k with ray
tracing i'm getting 60 fps it's not
perfect 60 but i'm doing ray tracing at
6k are you serious
oh
i just got owned
yo
what are you serious all right you know
what this time i'm gonna go to the
settings i'm gonna switch my texture
resolution to high particle quality high
shadow map extra i'm going all out guys
let's do this 59 fp 60fps 70f is this
supposed to happen oh watch this there's
someone in there
whoa
got one
he has shot me bro
are you serious dude i can't believe i
just maxed out all the settings at 6k
resolution that is absolutely insane i
can't believe it i'm still getting
excellent fps i'm gonna turn it down to
4k however we are gonna turn on
ray tracing
with everything turned up maxed out
let's do this are you serious all right
120 fps guys 4k everything maxed out
with ray tracing enabled absolutely
incredible
dude i'm sorry teammate bro
are you kidding bro oh come on all right
there you guys go hopefully you enjoyed
the gameplay in those three games and
i'm just shocked that we're able to play
6k resolution with awesome fps in each
game like metro exodus worked just fine
6k at medium over 60 no problems we had
a little bit of glitches when you went
up to high but that's a very graphically
demanding game in grand theft auto 5 it
wasn't as good as i expected but still
everything was good and in call of duty
war zone doing 6k at 60 fps around there
with ray tracing enabled i just have not
heard that ever on a mac it's just mind
blowing and then going down to 4k maxing
everything out with ray tracing with
above 100 fps that is just insane now
obviously if you're a gamer you should
not be buying a mac pro with the crazy
w6900x graphics card for six thousand
dollars that is absolutely overkill it
is super expensive the only reason you
should be buying that is if you're doing
some crazy i don't know blender
rendering 3d rendering some crazy raw
video editing something else that you're
actually doing work with to take
advantage of the crazy graphics card and
then on the side you can get basically
the best gaming experience possible on a
mac ever doing windows bootcamp or
playing games in mac os so i've got to
say that graphics card is insane and
this was really fun and knowing that we
could play basically any game we want to
with insane graphics settings at 6k
resolution if we want to that's awesome
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you did go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]